hey everyone Jared here one of the
creators here at wisecrack today we've
got another special episode about a show
that everyone is excited to see come
back on the air The Walking Dead The
Walking Dead is the tale of Sheriff Rick
Grimes and his small band of survivors
as they're transformed from coddled
complainers into battle-tested zombie
murdering badass it's also a show about
British actor Andrew Lincoln's struggle
to pronounce the name Carl certainly not
from the zombie sub-genre has a rich
history of social commentary and The
Walking Dead is no different whether
they be the slow walking brain craving
type or of the fast running shrieking
persuasion the figure of the zombie has
been a metaphor for all sorts of things
that keep us up at night
zombies have represented everything from
mindless consumers under capitalism in
Dawn of the Dead to fears about public
health crises in 28 days later
immigration in World War Z or mega
corporations in Resident Evil and then
there's the fact that zombies originated
in Haiti where many have argued it was a
metaphor for slavery zombies are
projections of our own societal fears
but The Walking Dead isn't quite any of
these sure it draws some parallels to
its predecessors such as when Andrea
picks out a necklace for her sister
while a horde of zombies clamor to eat
her similar to Dawn of the Dead we're
survivors take refuge in a shopping mall
and epitomize mindless consumers while
another kind of mindless consumer eerily
awaits the opportunity to indulge in
some organic Malta table meat instead
The Walking Dead explores a multitude of
issues like politics psychology and our
relationship to death
also the joys of cosplaying welcome to
this special episode on the philosophy
of The Walking Dead part 1 what does it
mean to live why are zombies so scary
it's not just the fact that getting
eaten alive probably sucks but our
revulsion at zombies provides deep
insights into how we view our own lives
after all plenty of things can rip out
our intestines and instead of inspiring
terror inspire the dulcet tones of
Vernor Hertzog I see only the
overwhelming indifference of nature
Zombies keep us up at night because
they're like us but not quite us they
also mess with the fundamental reason
that we use to tell ourselves that were
special the Walking Dead is above all
else a show about philosophical
boundaries and three in particular what
constitutes life what constitutes living
and what constitutes being human the
show is constantly asking us to
interrogate the difference between life
and death it is after all called the
Walking Dead and they're not just
talking about the zombies they're
talking about the survivors it raises
the question what makes us alive one of
the best moments of the show that
explores this happens early on at the
CDC but they're not alive you tell me
when it's revealed by dr. Jenner that
everyone is infected all the sudden the
line between Walker and humans seems a
bit blurred not only will everyone
reanimate but they're always so close to
death that the distinction seems to melt
away when they open the door to the CDC
Rick's group is blinded by a flood of
light clearly evoking the light at the
end of the tunnel to heaven or whatever
it is that people believe in these days
inside the CDC a brain scan shows the
small section of the Walker brain that
still lights up allowing them to move
and groan and eat but everything else is
turned off one could argue that this
means they're biologically alive they're
dead now no they're not different plenty
of animals like worms and insects do
just fine with not much more than what
the walkers are working with the show is
constantly exploring the distinction
between life and death
sometimes blurring it sometimes
questioning it sometimes affirming it
characters are constantly unable to let
go of their loved ones Morgan can't
shoot his wife and eventually loses his
son for it Hershel goes collecting
zombies like their Pokemon convinced
there's still something human about them
and the governor keeps his daughter
trapped in the closet I'm in the closet
like man what
going though in the scene where Andrea's
sister dies she seems to be lovingly
looking into the eyes of her sister
before we learned that warm embrace is
just the normal murdery zombie kind of
embrace if they have trouble letting go
of loved ones who have turned it's
because the definition of life was never
really clear to begin with we can break
up the questions of life into the
philosophical and biological census if
it's the ability to walk around and make
noises well the walkers already have
that covered but there's also the
philosophical question of life what
constitutes a life worth living
each character has their own reasons for
going on with life for Dale all life is
sacred
Dale admits that he just can't let go no
matter how bad things get even when his
own wife was dying from cancer after all
those surgeries
chemos she accepted it you know I never
could and I spent last few years so
angry
Carol values survival as its own into
but without all the saccharine moralism
no matter how terrible things get in her
life she just goes on surviving she's
utterly pragmatic secretly teaching kids
how to defend themselves pretending to
be a harmless housewife dressing up like
one of the wolves the list goes on and
of course there's this speech from Rick
as my grandpa wants if he ever killed
any Germans in the war said it was dead
manatees stepped into enemy territory
and then after a few years pretending he
was dead
and that's the trick of a that thing we
do what we need to do the question at
hand here at the CDC and throughout the
show seems to be what's the point of
living if we're already dead is the
small glimmer of electric life inside
the brains of the Dead that much
different that the tiny glimmer of hope
that allows Rick in the group to beast
through this hell on earth for Rick
being biologically alive is simply a
means to an end for the chance that one
day you'll get to live according to our
old friend Albert Camus there is but one
truly philosophical problem and that is
suicide at the CDC Jenner Andrea and
Jackie decided there's no point to live
a life devoid of meaning and full of
misery and want to end it there's
nothing but for Camus despite the
meaninglessness of it all suicide isn't
liberating only Life offers us freedom
the rest of Rick's group cling to a
notion of freedom not exactly can lose
notion of freedom and keep going and
then they you know lock themselves up in
a prison for the sake of surviving
another philosophical question at hand
in the Walking Dead is what makes us
human or put the other way what makes us
not a zombie we could say that unlike
zombies humans have purpose and for one
don't hunger for flesh except well we're
literally confronted with a band of
cannibals and the existential question
of the show seems to be if the survivors
are just aimlessly wandering around
without a purpose from one source of
sustenance to the next and eventually
have to resort to cannibalism then what
really differentiates them from the
zombies this blurry distinction between
human and animal leads to a dilemma a
dilemma that is constantly driving the
survivors to distance themselves from
the walkers most survivors want to be
killed so they can't turn if you die
before you've turned you get a proper
burial and huge parts of the second
season center around Herschel's refusal
to lose empathy for his turned loved
ones it seems that everything that comes
to define us as humans is stripped away
leaving only our biological cells rick
is no longer a cop but a man searching
for his offspring and mating partner
social distinctions are allegedly gone
things are different there are no
knickers in her no dumbest [ __ ] inbred
white-trash fools either on the dark
meat and white meat there's us and the
dead
Glenn used to be a delivery guy now he's
just really good at sneaking around
still the survivors still desperately
cling to symbols that used to define
their humanity symbols that in grand
scheme of things seem kind of stupid
rick is constantly losing and recovering
his sheriff's hat before bestowing it on
Carl a reminder of Rick past life and
the law
Carol misses her Maytag Andrea takes a
mermaid necklace itself an amalgam of
man and beast for her sister and the
show's creators really really want to
show us how awesome hot showers are so
in other words a big part of what
separates humans from animals seems to
be our social status our stuff and hot
showers what makes humans well human is
one of philosophies oldest questions
Aristotle for instance argued that our
ability to speak and reason
separated us from animals who merely had
the ability to grunt base needs in the
world of zombies the very idea that a
human has lost their ability to reason
and speak warrants the claim that
they're no longer human then again we
could also think of the small part of
the brain animating the walkers as the
animal part of our own brain part 2
moral lines in the world of The Walking
Dead zombies aren't always the scariest
thing out there the show is constantly
exhibiting humanity's worst abusive
partners rapists bandits whatever the
hell the wolves are doing and of course
terminus the fact that the home of the
cannibals is named after a Roman god
isn't a coincidence terminus is the
Roman god of boundaries and throughout
the show were confronted with oh so many
boundaries being crossed not only do its
denizens survive by eating human flesh
but it's captives are kept in train cars
that evoke Nazi death camps Carol even
stumbles upon a room of possessions
stolen from their victims Rick's group
is brought to the floor of an industrial
slaughterhouse where Garrett's henchmen
first knock out their victims and then
slice their throats as if they were
cattle Gareth calmly walks in with a
notebook asking
henchmen what they're shot counts were
for accounting purposes where were your
shot counts we could probably make a
whole episode about this scene alone but
what we've got here is a series of
binaries human zombie human animal good
evil civilization barbarism all being
blurred the residents of terminus have
simultaneously lost their humanity and
yet ironically have exhibited humanity's
crowning achievement bureaucracy these
boundaries function as more than just
empty rhetoric they're deeply productive
for better or worse the line between
human and animal serves as a framework
for how people should live their lives
before and after the zombie apocalypse
but it also demarcates what gets screwed
over in the distinction cattle spoilers
it sucks to be the cattle it's why the
show focuses so much on the group's
struggled to retain their humanity the
residents of terminus weren't always
like this
and function as a sort of cautionary
tale for surviving in the zombie
apocalypse originally an actual
sanctuary for survivors a group of
bandits rolled in and proceeded to lock
its inhabitants and train cars before
sexually assaulting and eventually
murdering when the original residents of
terminus successfully rebel they lock
their tormentor in a train car to rot
where he spends his time yelling it
becomes clear that morality along with
Maytag in a shower is what separates us
from animals when escaping from terminus
Rick wants to abandon the others trapped
in the train cars until Glenn convinces
him that helping others is essential to
their identity still we are in the
episode judge jury and executioner
excuses faced with the decision of what
to do with a captured survivor who may
or may not imperil the group if let go
Dale is convinced that the loss of
justice equates the loss of humanity the
world we know is gone but keeping our
humanity that's a choice even Gareth
likens the signs that would lead to his
torture with his humanity we were baby
yeah what are we now Gareth other
citizens determinists equate morals with
the inability to survive you're a good
guy that's why you're gonna die today
clearly being human is more than just a
set of biological questions what The
Walking Dead really explores is that
there are many many things that define
our humanity a critical point in all
this is whether or not the walkers
maintain a shred of their former selves
let me ask you something
do you still believe the bodies have
some spark in them or who they were I
think so
then again one doesn't have to turn to
become a monster I knew Phillip before
he became the governor that man still
exists just as we question whether the
undead maintained any element of their
past identity we also asked do those
alive but morally contaminated retain
any sense of their former selves this is
further explored through the character
of Morgan after his wife and son died
Morgan loses not only himself but his
connection to reality but he survived
with the help of a former psychiatrist
who teaches him that no person is too
far gone to be rehabilitated it's why
Morgan refuses to kill even the Wolves
who most consider to have lost every
last bit of their humanity part three
dictatorship a recurring theme in the
show is the struggle between
dictatorship and democracy as it turns
out trying the juggle finding food
maintaining a shelter and not getting
murdered is pretty complicated
especially when multiple people are we
see early on the complications that
arise from this arguments about where to
go how to get there who needs to do what
and what to do when people break the
rules also who's in charge while Rick's
group of survivors talk it out the
always imminent backup plan is shir of
violence not to mention that when the
walkers are coming talking it out isn't
always the most expedient solution when
Shane and Rick can't see eye-to-eye on
anything anymore both of them conclude
it's murdering time with Rick eventually
winning as the show progresses Rick is
more or less in charge but the most
interesting thing happens at the end of
season 2 when Rick openly declares a
dictatorship this isn't a democracy it's
important to note the origin of
dictatorships the term originally comes
from the ancient Roman legal convention
where an absolute power was bestowed
upon an individual in cases of extreme
emergency while now the term is thrown
around to indicate shitty rulers and
people we think resemble those shitty
rulers the Roman dictatorship was in the
sucess 'ti to protect against utter
annihilation from invading armies the
famous good guy dictator was Cincinnatus
Cincinnatus was a Roman statesman who
after his son ran into some legal
trouble sold most of his land and
retired to a small farm when Rome was an
imminent danger from a neighboring
Italian tribe the Roman consul elected
Cincinnatus to the position of dictator
as legend goes a group of senators were
dispatched to tell Cincinnatus the news
and found him plowing his farm since
then as put on his toga headed for Rome
defeated the bad guys and immediately
resigned his position as dictator later
Cincinnatus was elected dictator again
this time to save Rome from a coup and
again once the coup was stopped
Cincinnatus resigned and went back to
farming did we mention that Rick Grimes
is totally Cincinnatus not like Oh Rick
Grimes kind of reminds us of this other
guy who had absolute power in the face
of scary invaders but like oh this guy
leaves his life as a farmer to protect
against hordes of enemies only to go
back to farming when the threat is gone
this Roman Connection is suspiciously
everywhere in the show
the governor's Fight Club is reminiscent
of gladiator battles and as previously
mentioned terminus is the Roman god of
boundaries the Bible verse where Jesus
rises from the dead Romans 6:4 which is
scrawled on Gabriel's wall
it's not exactly clear what the show's
creators are doing here it could just be
that Roman history is a treasure trove
of material when you're trying to think
of creative ways drama could play out in
a hyper violent society always on the
lookout for hordes of invaders but in
doing so the walking dead ends up making
some really smart commentary on politics
and specifically sovereignty Rome after
all was the site of both history's most
extreme tyrants and foundational
representative government part for state
of exception what makes a ruler
according to controversial German
political theorist Carl Schmitt the
sovereign is whoever makes the exception
whether you're living in the United
States or ancient Rome the sovereign is
always the person who can discard the
law to carve out exceptions to the rule
it's kind of like your shitty hometown
mayor who has the police looked the
other way when his relatives drink and
drive or smoke crack yes I have some
work to crack cocaine the most obvious
example of this is Rick
Cincinnatus Grimes who simply declares
that democracy time is over but we also
see that when Alexandria is an imminent
danger it's Rick not Deanna who's in
charge I know you're gonna say it's not
up to you it can be the law is
constantly being suspended and not only
by Rick Schoen bypasses the will of the
group and kills Randall in the woods
Carol kills and burns flu victims in the
prison to stop it from threatening the
group in fact shames criticism of Rick
seems to be heavily rooted in Rick's
ability to make the exception when he
won't execute Randall Italian
philosopher George au agamben argues
that the state of exception has become
the law of our time no longer an
infrequent occurrence the suspension of
law permeates our society we see it in
the war on terror and refugee camps
around the world a gunman wanted to
figure out just how the Nazi
concentration camps could happen and it
was in this state of exception that he
found his answer but because we're
talking about the Walking Dead let's put
it this way Rick is your typical modern
sovereign he suspends the law to get
[ __ ] done and to save people I told for
the good of everyone I thought it best
if people didn't know sometimes that
means Rick does really messed-up things
the difference between Rick and Gareth
is only that the suspension of law has
become permanent in terminus sure
there's order but the denizens of
terminus have thrown aside the most
basic laws of human morality like don't
eat pee and for a Gambon the idea that
all the Rick's of the world are only a
few setbacks away from becoming
is terrifying the show makes it really
clear why as we discussed earlier all
these atrocities are in the name of
survival the whole you're either the
butcher or the cattle might as well be
the familiar tale of the bird of prey
and the lamb espoused by Nietzsche who
of course the Nazis love to take out of
context in their own propaganda rick is
constantly invoking this us or them
logic that they can't keep up you keep
going suggesting that what separates
Rick from Gareth may not be all that
much as Agamben says the camp is the
space that opens up when the state of
exception starts to become the rule a
problem with all this Agamben argues is
that whether or not atrocities are
committed whether or not bob is for
breakfast is dependent on the law
enforcer as sovereign rather than the
rule of law and while we're not living
in the zombie apocalypse that logic
still rules the day whether it's swine
flu natural disasters or Isis the
ability of the government to suspend the
law is always image conclusion the
walking dead continues to be one of the
smartest shows on TV and despite being
set in a fictional zombie apocalypse
it's questions still hit pretty close to
home questions like what makes life
worth living what makes us human and in
what circumstances am I allowed to
resort to cannibalism again it's unclear
where the show will go will Rick and his
groups save the world and build anew or
will Rick continue to ruin every place
he comes across or in the end will the
world need to be saved from Rick thanks
for watching everyone I hope you enjoyed
this special episode on The Walking Dead
if you're not already a subscriber to
wisecrack be sure to go to our channel
page and subscribe
well the walkers eventually kill off all
of humanity will humanity outlive the
zombie apocalypse and take back control
of Earth click here to check out a
special episode by Matt Patton our
friends over at the film theorists as he
tackles these questions and more it's an
amazing episode in the perfect
supplement to ours so head over there
and make sure to subscribe while you're
over there all right guys I got to get
back to work on the Final Fantasy
episode be sure to follow us on Twitter
Facebook all that good stuff the links
are in the description below and as
always thank you so much for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]